there's all-time greats says farewell to  the world's most famous arena is Dwyane  Wade in the heat with an important wind  will their playoff hopes having a chat  with our aunt Louise didn't like  something that was either call to 912e  he finished with 16 points 7 rebounds  and 3 assists he will be a first-ballot  hall-of-famer no question about it  [Music]  three-time champion said he's always  loved playing here at Madison Square  Garden he felt the love tonight  introduced in the starting lineups a  rousing ovation his former assistant  coach with the need david says dale  McMillon career six more regular season  games left and perhaps a playoff  appearance one more time  yeah they've got an early don't like if  you did two very tough finish for the  heat to try to get it to the playoffs  Orlando winning tonight and in the heat  winning so they stood in the eighth spot  Miami does a half game ahead